buonasera a tutti abbiamo probabilmente
letto tutti quanti noi in un giornale
locale
qualche tempo fa questa notizia qualche
settimana fa la guardia di finanza ha
scoperto tra le altre cose un certo
numero di guide turistiche cinesi
abusive bene ovviamente nessuno qui
vuole giustificare l'abusivismo anzi la
è da condannare evidentemente da da
reprimere però questa notizia nasconde
una serie di notizie probabilmente che
non siamo sempre in grado di cogliere
nasconde delle opportunità che appunto
non sono sempre visibili e sono le
opportunità che nascono dalla
globalizzazione della cosiddetta
globalizzazione
se prendiamo la cina come paese
emblematico della globalizzazione
forse le opportunità emergono in maniera
più chiara guardando questi numeri il
grafico di sinistra vi dice quanto
l'economia cinese è cresciuta negli
ultimi 12 13 anni un tasso di crescita
stabilmente superiore a quello di
un'economia chiamiamo la tradizionale
come quella degli stati uniti è un paese
che cresce porta con sé delle
opportunità le porta evidentemente per
le persone e le imprese di quel paese ma
porta opportunità anche per tutta una
serie di altri paesi e molte opportunità
dalla crescita della cina vengono anche
per l'italia se ne sappiamo cogliere
guardiamo il grafico di destra quella è
la classe media cinese che ci aspettiamo
da qui al 2020 la classe media cinese
sarà sette volte superiore alla classe
media che c'era solamente nel 2006 bene
la classe media che cresce significa una
classe che media che va a spendere una
classe media che alimenta i flussi
turistici di prima e della classe media
che probabilmente sarà anche molto
interessata a comprare i prodotti del
made in italy di cui abbiamo sentito
parlare prima e di qui in questo è il
proprio in questi giorni è uscita
un'interessante statistica che dice che
i cinesi sono molto più interessati a
comprare i prodotti del made in italy
quando vengono in italia perché sono
sicuri o almeno si aspettano di essere
sicuri che non sono contraffatti
cosa che ci lascia anche per certi versi
quasi
perché non siamo in grado di cogliere le
opportunità che la globalizzazione ci
mette a disposizione uno degli aspetti
potrebbe essere anche collegato al fatto
che non sappiamo leggere correttamente
la cultura di quel paese ea leggere la
cultura un elemento invece fondamentale
per poter cogliere le opportunità la
cultura come dice uno degli studiosi più
importanti delle culture nazionali the
art of sede è il software della mente ed
è fatta di tanti elementi si può
immaginare come un iceberg che ha una
parte emersa quella più piccola fatta di
comportamenti ma che ma che ha anche
tutta una serie di altri elementi che
non sono visibili come le regole i
valori le emozioni ogni assunti di base
che sono però collegati ai comportamenti
e conoscere la cultura di un paese
nel caso specifico la cina è importante
perché la cultura influenza il modo con
il quale le persone comunicano negoziano
che concezione hanno del tempo piuttosto
che tipo di relazioni anno tra pari o
con l'autorità come impostano i processi
decisionali
qual è il senso di appartenenza alla
comunità o come si approcciano di font
di fronte alla collaborazione sono tutti
aspetti che sono importanti e che
bisogna appunto conoscere e saper
individuare qual è il modo migliore per
conoscere una cultura se non quello di
andare a sperimentare con la cultura
abbiamo sentito anche in uno degli
speech iniziali andare a sperimentare la
cultura nel paese di origine
ed è qui che l'università deve avere un
ruolo un ruolo fondamentale che è quello
di creare esperienze di formazione
multiculturale
qui in italia piuttosto che in cina la
foto che vedete lì è la summer school
che è stata fatta che abbiamo fatto
l'estate scorsa mettendo insieme una
classe italiana è una classi cinese però
l'università appunto deve fare altro
deve creare anche esperienze di lavoro
si diego e io infatti ho avuto
l'opportunità di sperimentare la seconda
opzione andando a fare la mia primissima
esperienza di lavoro in cina dove in
cina bea cinta hoc e precisamente una
piccola cittadina di una decina di
milioni di abitanti nel nord est della
cina e che forse qualcuno di voi
ricorderà per la birra cinta o ma perché
fare la propria prima esperienza di
lavoro in cina
le statistiche ci dicono che ogni anno
ci sono 7 milioni di laureati cinesi che
entrano nel mondo del lavoro globale i
loro papà sicuramente fanno parte della
classe dirigente di oggi ma questi
laureati ancor più sicuramente faranno
parte della classe dirigente di domani
ecco che quindi io ho avuto
l'opportunità di andarli a conoscere a
capirli e soprattutto a capire cosa ci
accomuni e cosa no e difatti che cosa
c'è da imparare in cina
beh al di là di usi e costumi una lingua
totalmente diversi ingredienti culinari
innovativi se vogliamo c'è da imparare
una cultura che va ad influenzare come
diceva prima francesca tutti i
comportamenti delle persone in
particolare le dinamiche del mondo del
lavoro
la cina è infatti in cina tutto si basa
sulle relazioni
voi direte beh sì anche qui è così
niente di nuovo
però lì ci sono altri due aspetti da
considerare è il primo riguarda il
rispetto della gerarchia delle
convenzioni della formalità e delle
etichette in generale
il secondo aspetto riguarda invece la
salvaguardia della faccia propria dei
colleghi o degli amici come dicevamo
tutto questo va a influenzare le
dinamiche soprattutto per quanto ho
avuto modo di sperimentare io dal punto
di vista lavorativo e vi faccio un
esempio eravamo alla vigilia di un
importante evento lì in cina quale
avrebbe partecipato tutto il top
management italiano dell'azienda per su
cui lavoravo e come in questi casi
eravam irritata con i preparativi qui in
italia cosa sarebbe successo caos il
capo inviperito i colleghi che tra di
loro cercavano di capire chi fosse
responsabile
invece niente di tutto questo tutti
erano tranquilli nessuno incolpava
nessun altro il capo non era inviperito
e perché perché il capo non poteva far
perdere la faccia a se stessa ai propri
collaboratori e c'era comunque rispetto
della gerarchia cosa è successo alla
fine niente è successo che abbiamo
comunque raggiunto il nostro obiettivo
tutto è stato preparato in tempo e da
qui
credo che forse noi abbiamo davvero
qualcosa da imparare da loro
quindi diego non ci resta quindi che
incoraggiare tutti i giovani a cercare
nel loro percorso di studi delle
esperienze multiculturali perché
crediamo che solo così saranno in grado
di cogliere le opportunità che la
società e l'economia di domani metterà
loro a disposizione
grazie